it's okay to not be okay it's okay to  talk about mental health and i think  what we've done is we've packaged it up  as an employee offering that isn't just  about you know flexibility that isn't  just about innovation that isn't about  well-being it's actually about a  complete employee offering without  compromise you know  the other thing we had to think about is  people do the job for money we wanted to  have the strongest commission structure  that's actually achievable that isn't  just on paper looks good but impossible  to achieve in practice so  that is how we are different that we  offer a lot to employees but they know  they're not compromised they can  literally  achieve more money with pivot than they  can anywhere else the recruitment  mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by  vincerie and the award-winning sauce  breaker